[Music]
Jeff Snyder here at the Kia telluride
supper suite in Park City and I'm
sitting down with the team behind Sergio
we've got director Greg Barkin producers
Brent Travers and Daniel Dreyfuss and
international superstar Wagner Moura
thanks for coming guys you guys so far
it's also it's been great yeah we had a
sweet screen for the volunteers on
opening night which was the first time
we saw it with an audience of hidden
friends so it's kind of amazing it was
amazing it was at first the first yeah
for some reason we screened the film in
front of our knowledge it was it seemed
like the perfect audience for this film
for this particular film and I'm also in
the juror of the world competition in
this year so I'm gonna be till the end
of the festival watching movies so it's
been you can't watch anything right you
just stay here and yeah so you don't you
don't really see the films I do my best
I do my best I wish I had seen this one
you know and I'm definitely gonna check
it out when he hits Netflix in April but
Craig tell us you know you directed a
documentary like a decade ago about
about Sergio tell me about you know
turning that into a narrative feature it
was also called Sergio we were here 11
years ago exactly the same week that
Barack Obama was inaugurated so taking
that story out in that context and now
is very different you know I I am it's a
film about empathy and and hope set
against the darkness and how one guy
Sergio Vieira de Melo un diplomat
struggles with life's purpose and
finding connections with those closest
to him you know it's the story that has
been in my head for a long time I
actually saw it when I first heard about
the real story I saw it as a movie this
was back in 2005 initially and made as a
documentary but always wanted to return
to the subject matter on an emotional
level as a narrative and so it's great
to be back at the festival all these
years later with with this incredible
cast and and Branton Daniel how did you
guys get involved what appealed to you
about sergio story you know our story I
think is kind of an interesting one as
well because Daniel and I had been
friends and known each other for a long
time
but Daniel and Greg had actually been
developing a Sergio project together
years ago and then Wagner and I were on
a separate track and we've been looking
for projects to do together and then one
day we get a phone call and you know
it's like one of your friends calling up
and saying hey I wanted to do this as
well and we merged our projects and we
had the same vision for the film in the
same emotional core to the film and it
was as easy as that and you know
normally so many films will smother and
die or cancel each other out and really
that's not what happened it thrived
because of you know Greg's documentary
we were all behind that and we you know
we were so passionate about the material
and though just out of that that I
actually met Greg originally at Sundance
I had seen the documentary years prior
but these festivals like this also
served that purpose in addition to all
the movies you eventually meet people
that you click with creatively we were
introduced literally he made this
documentary then he was interested in
this type of film and a partnership was
born right then and there and a few
years later we're back here where we met
or it all started for us at least for
this particular project so it's
wonderful to be at a festival where we
have this creative energy around us can
you tell me about getting into the
headspace of playing this character I
think this is this is the third
character in a role that I play someone
that really existed so I did Pablo
Escobar and I did this film with Olivier
Assayas about the Cuban spies in in
Miami last Network the wasp Network this
one and then I directed a film in Brazil
about the Brazilian revolutionary called
charismatic gala so I was dealing with
real characters which was something
pretty new to me till that point - Pablo
and the way I think I think the best way
to approach these real characters is
trying to know everything about them you
know studying and reading and watching
I've seen Gregg's documentary a hundred
times and but then I think an actor has
to forget all that and then to create
like I created my own version of surgery
you know because in the end of the day
that's what
we actors do right so it's it's based on
a real character we had a lot of
responsibility towards that character
and but it's it's it's in a way it's
also a creation of us if the film had to
work as it's the documentary was already
made so it had to work as a feature for
Greg you Ana de Armas is your female
lead here and you're catching her at a
pretty incredible time I mean she is
just red hot right now they're talking
about casting her and working with her
she's amazing in the movie and a great
incredible talent and it's it's
wonderful to see what's happening with
her with her career I mean the way it
came about I mean it was very
serendipitous it was a friend one of our
actors who plays Sergio's bodyguard had
dinner with Daniel and happened to
mention that he was having dinner that
night with honored Armas who was already
top of our list
yeah so Daniel very in the great
producer way said can you slip her the
script to mention the project which he
did and that was on a Friday and by
Monday she was at my house having read
the script saying I have to play Clara
Karolina don't talk to anybody else
Wow Zoltan just so I mean it was it was
you could you know I think we didn't
know it was gonna happen to her but
based on her past work we weren't
surprised you could see when the when we
started rehearsing and enrolling that
it's I mean the chemistry and the magic
was just was kind of leaping off the
screen like giving you guys oh I think
she's a she's one of the most talented
actors that have ever worked with she's
very talented
and she has this superstar quality and
we all kind of knew that Ana was gonna
be like huge you know in an accent in
next years and she's a she became a very
good friend of all of us and she's a
she's adorable she's great and I'm just
bummed that she's not here because she's
working she's working on stuff I'm more
bummed would be great to have her when
we first yeah she'll be for the other
press for the film but when we first
rehearse their scenes we spent three
days in a hotel
reowww just going through all that right
and they sort of discovered we did the
whole chronology of their relationship
and when they were from they met all the
way through and you could see it was
just like oh my goodness this is gonna
leap off the screen and it does
I mean you've assembled a great ensemble
here I have huge respect for character
actors and you have three of the greats
Brian fo burn garret dillahunt Bradley
Whitford those guys are tremendous
conveying about how they always sort of
came together they Rock you know I have
to say you know part of our process with
the film weather was with the the
supporting cast or even with our
department heads everybody who read the
script and had seen Greg's documentary
especially all wanted to do the film so
wasn't we didn't have to do any
convincing er thing else but I mean
Garrett loved it
when you see Bradley Whitford is Paul
Bremer he embodies all the things that
you but he's not what you expect I think
all of us we had we had an idea in our
own mind but you know it's Paul Bremer
or the US ambassador envoy to Iraq who
who kind of messes things up in real
life and can be kind of like seen as a
caricature in a way and and so we feel
actually films somewhat like there was a
phone call that we filmed when Sergio is
talking to Bremer and we filmed that
scene of bargainer side of it and
Bradley shows up and sort of brings us
whole different human connection to this
we had to shoot it again maybe shoot it
again because he was like his motto was
for Bremer was yes we can't I said but
he was that mean in the scenes you guys
have together I mean I I'm one of the
producers of the film so I had the
chance to kind of participate in the
casting of the food which for us was so
I I must say this is the perfect cast
you know and brian is here Gary yes
there they are
they all are gonna be in in our in our
premiere Bradley's not gonna make it is
also film but I think it's I have so
much respect and which one of each actor
of this film I was like working with
them I had a lot of scenes with Brandon
in there in a shaft in in in in the
rubble yeah which were the most
complicated part of the film for in
emotionally and technically and and so
we were like basically Brian and I
that in a weird position inside and that
was I learned so much in each one of
these actors they have very different
methods like Anna is very like she's led
by her intuition and she just goes there
and and she'd desert and in which is
amazing and brilliant studies each line
of in then we were rehearsing so I was
learning so much and and of course
working with Bradley who is an actor
that I always admired so much so I was
very lucky well I will Craig Borden be
at the premiere because I loved Dallas
buyers yeah because I about sort of met
that script and how it developed over
the years maybe what what changed
I mean Craig whoa I mean Craig's did an
amazing work on this and I think the
great sort of you know he had a
complicated relationship with his own
father and kind of identity saw his his
own father and Sergio and so what I
always would drew me to Craig from the
first met was his emotional connection
with material and is his desire to
explore so did Sergio's inner turmoil he
had he came up with this kind of very
ambitious innovative structure we were
all sort of inspired by diving bell and
the butterfly I love that we love that
movie Julian Schnabel amazing and and
that kind of playing with time and and
structure and memory Craig really kind
of cracked that on his first draft and
then we spent a lot of time you know
refining over that over over over the
months and then it comes out April 17th
on Netflix April 17th the Netflix and in
select theaters near you and we're very
excited thank you guys for coming in the
team behind Sergio thank you to the key
a separ suite